[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's woken
up to worst girls and jen walters let me
bloody tell you episode 4 of she-hulk is
now out and the entry is packed with
easter eggs comic call backs and also a
lot of things that set up the future of
the series jen ends up dating and when
her date sees her in real life in the
morning he ends up going out quicker
than a heavy spoilers breakdown this is
a motif that pops up time and time again
in the comics and the dance slot run
actually featured something similar to
this in the opening issue jen woke up
with a model and she realized that he
probably wasn't too interested in her so
she quickly transformed into she-hulk
which broke the bed this was somewhat
touched upon in the first episode when
she also did the same thing out in
mexico i kinda hope that jen's arc ends
with her finding a guy she likes and
while she goes to bed with her as she
hulk she decides to stay in human form
in the morning because she wants them to
accept her this could end up happening
with pug who knows jen on a personal
level and he was also a love interest in
the comics you see guys i believe in
true love but i also believe in true
likes so [ __ ] hit that thumbs up
button yeah [ __ ] hit it need to pay
for my divorce i got caught liking
she-hulk's photo on tinder and i've been
kicked out the house so i'd also
appreciate this sub anyway without the
way huge thank you for clicking the
video now let's get into she-hulk
episode 4.
[Music]
now up top i just want to give a huge
thank you for getting us to the one
million subscriber mark i'm absolutely
blown away by it thank you so much for
the support i'm actually away next week
but for something special on the channel
we're going to be doing a live stream
the week after so i'd love to see you
over there hopefully we can get you all
involved and just talk about the good
times
come on
this guy hit a million before me
his accent is clearly fake the internet
don't know what's good anymore
now as many of you know we get some of
these episodes early from disney i'll
watch each episode a couple of days
before you guys do and there's been one
thing that's kept me up night and day
for the last 48 hours for weeks now
twitter has been buzzing with the idea
that johnny blaze aka ghost rider will
be in the show this is because posters
for the character were apparently seen
in the trailer but here we see that it's
actually just donnie blaze now i'd of
course love to hear if you were
disappointed in this reveal or not or if
you think it's some top tier ralph bona
trolling that feige is famous for maybe
you didn't know but let me know below
now the episode opens on donny
performing a magic show turns out he was
training in the mystic arts but that he
ended up dropping out he performed some
of these spells without really knowing
what he's doing and the entry centers
around wong attempting to put a stop to
this through the correct legal channels
donnie is played by rhys corio and his
wife cat directed six of the nine
episodes of she-hulk so i do kind of
wonder how he got this job now donny
also uses a sling ring to open her
portals and interestingly johnny blaze
uses chains and agents of shield to open
them up too now he opened on the
griffith observatory which popped up as
a picture back in jen's office during
episode 1. this is a staple of lay and
it's also where the james dean movie
rebel without a cause was shot where
donnie is is a private theater though
and we actually see a cool easter egg
around his neck here you can catch what
appears to be a bird head with a beak
later on we get a better look at it and
i'm sure that this is a necklace of
consu the moon guard of course appeared
throughout moon night and with this
episode being centered around the occult
makes a lot of sense for an odd to him
to be popping up the entry is filled
with a talk of demons and devils and it
reminded me of a one division breakdown
most of donny's tricks are fake though
and we see as he levitates during the
show really nice detail when he put his
feet on the ground and if you look
closely you can actually see him
unclipping the wire that allowed him to
suspend in the air he summons vile like
my man johnny blaze and ends up
introducing us to madison madison with
two n's one y but it's not where you
think
wow so how do you spell it
m-a-d-i-s-y-n-n
so we are now officially in the mcu the
madison cinematic universe and her and
wong is about to change the way that
movies are made donnie also ends up
dropping this quote as the great billy
shakes once said
a rose by any other name
which pulls from the william shakespeare
play romeo and juliet he transforms some
plastic flowers into roses and madison
ends up referencing these later on in
court so first he gave me roses that
don't smell like anything with the
audience unimpressed he ends up creating
a portal and this looks like it goes to
some dark game of thrones realm with the
kinds of severed heads that you'd see on
house of the dragon now house of the
dragon shortened is hot d and i kinda
hope that wong gave madison some hot d
now we cut to kathmandu and we catch him
watching the sopranos in comitage i'm
one of those people who hasn't actually
seen it before yes yes i know i need to
sort my life out so i was actually like
whoa with a mate when madison started
ruining major plot points from it she
spoiled the spoiler man
so that's what that feels like
and i'm bloody furious now the hints
towards him watching this are given to
us early on as we can hear the theme
tune playing over the top of the
location
yes i've not seen it yet but but another
theme tune mate now we catch wong about
to sit down on his couch and as he's
seemingly halfway through the series i'm
guessing this is why he was late last
week to the hearing as he jumped through
the portal you could actually see the
couch behind him so he'd probably just
been wrapped up in his favorite show
madison ends up showing up in the room
holding a heart which ties into the
sacrifice that she had to make she asks
where the goblins are and also thinks
that wong might be the goblin king now
this could be a nod of the goblin nation
which were a group in the comics led by
the green goblin he was referred to as
the goblin king but there wasn't really
the supernatural element to them that we
get here now behind here we can catch
that wong is watching season 5 episode
12 which is titled long term parking
could have googled this to tell you what
happens in the episode but i won't spoil
stuff for you and that's why i need a
thumbs up you'll also be pleased to know
that we fired jared from jared's easter
eggs
[Music]
all you guys complaining about him he
finally got us to get rid of him so he
fired him from that and then gave him
gave him a permanent hosting job doing
the ending explains for a couple of
movies a month
you suck oh i'm one guy yeah i've just
had kids i need the help i need the help
are we cutting jed and we see her
wearing an oversized man suit i noticed
this on our she-hulk video last week and
pointed it out there so it's nice to be
vindicated with us getting her wearing
it whilst she's in gen form this looks
massive on her but she has to wear it in
order for it to fit when she transforms
into she-hulk nikki later says she's
gotta get herself some new clothes but
there's probably not that much that's
going to fit here and we also get a
little fourth wall break here god
everybody loves wong it's like
giving the show twitter armor for a week
we'll see how they handle the donnie
blaze thing first mate but her dad shows
up due to the wrecking crew attack last
week in case you don't know these were a
group in the comics who gained their
abilities from a magical crowbar that
was struck by lightning but in the
series they've just robbed an asgardian
construction worker we did theorize that
they might be working for titania and
with her suing jen at the end of the
episode it could tie in with that in the
comics titania's origin story ties in
with dr doom and he helped to bulk her
up during the events of secret wars
episode 1 laid the foundation for her
blood being something that could help
make her the hulks and with the crew
trying to grab her dna last week it
might end up being all connected
however they also worked for the hood in
the comics who we know is due to debut
and iron heart this would set up more
events for the future and obviously let
me know below what you think is going on
now jen's dad arrives to protect her and
he's brought a shovel to bury the bodies
you sick son of a [ __ ] now we also get
a quick glance at her book collection
when she leans against the wall and you
can catch the girl with a dragon tattoo
on it i have no idea how this ties in
with the show and the only person in
marvel with a dragon tattoo is iron fist
so maybe this is a hint to him i'm
fisting her on a date down the life
sorry keep forgetting my mum watches
these videos i need to cut those kinds
of jokes anyway that book followed two
characters the first of which was
investigating a familial disappearance
the second though was elizabeth a
computer hacker who stood up to the men
in her life won most notably by
tattooing him with your word after he
abused her it's very much a story about
a woman who's been beaten down in life
standing up against those that push her
down she's definitely a powerful woman
which might be a tenuous reach or it
might just be some nice set dressing
that helps to add to the idea of what
she-hulk stands for later on we see that
her date ends up reading bad feminist by
roxane gay this book also could have
several meanings to it and it's about
celebrating being a feminist whilst also
loving the things that seem like they're
at odds with it the book how to make
friends and influence people is also
referenced when we go to the law firm
and see jen's to-do list the book is
actually called how to win friends and
influence people but with it being
published in the 1930s the common
grammar for it has changed because no
one says how to win friends anymore
especially because all you know how to
do is lose friends see you chump so we
have a handful of important books all
which have their own meanings might just
be reading into it but if you have your
own thoughts then you know where you can
shove them
write down in the comments section now
jen's to-do list also contains several
things that refer to other elements of
the series we have a couple of top
referring to emil blonsky aka the
abomination this includes finalizing his
injunction preparing guidance for his
inhibitor and also contacting his parole
officer down from that jen has a note to
order purple and green highlighters and
these colors are of course synonymous
with the hulk next says a little joke
about editing the to-do list which will
take two hours and hey we see how long
it is you also have meet nikki in the
bathroom interviews for associates with
a frown face that's then juxtaposed by
the smile face for when she organizes
the outings finish the ruiner paperwork
with pug which refers to last week and
also sign up for a big and tall
membership due to her clothes not
fitting she then speeds through these
and i slowed down the footage so i could
read him i'll just go through the
highlights though so we aren't here all
day now one reads about following up on
blonsky's soulmates there's a meeting
with mallory burke who we met last week
one about ordering new cheetos and a
follow-up to that about ordering more
chopsticks which is then followed up by
saying that she won't waste we then have
research precedence on likeness ip for
ms pete as well as a cease and desist
for pete v rooney in case you don't know
megan the stallion's real name is meg
and pete so this ties in with that we
have a mention of bukowski a coffee date
with pug and nikki finding a direct
contact line for wong eating one
home-cooked meal this week some of the
cases and to finish up her dating
profile this is what she goes to first
and as she builds this tinder parody you
can catch a qr code on screen that will
link you to a free shield comic now
along the bottom of the screen we can
actually catch the full name of the law
firm which is known as goodman libra
kurzberg and holloway outside of
holloway these are all nods to important
creators at marvel goodman is for modern
goodman libra is a reference to
stanley's real surname and kurtzberg is
a reference to jack kirby's real name
jacob kurtzbach the law firm also popped
up in the comics with only holloway
being a character we met because he's
not based on any real figures and we see
more of jen's interview from last week
on tv but it's interrupted by wong lads
rocking the same hell and that he had in
multiverse of madness well depending on
on what scene you watch because them
reshoots they had him with a different
hairstyle minute by minute like kelly
osbourne on bo selector a he once donnie
blaise made an example of but as he
didn't get him to sign an nda he doesn't
really have a leg to stand on she-hulk
finally gets wong's caught in a bit of a
magic trick and we cut to the legal ball
where she finishes up a cease and desist
after some guy tries to chat them up at
the bar the talk turns to the dating
scene and nikki ends up doing an
inception and putting it in her head
that she needs to appear as she-hulk
from here we go to cornelius p willow's
office neither his name or the mr castle
are things that i think has any link to
the comics but let me know if you have
any knowledge of what is character ties
to i think the mystic castle is probably
just the place where donny has the shows
as as it does sort of look like a castle
i guess and wong and she hulk have
brought a warning to stop what they're
doing but it falls on daffy's great
little bit where donnie makes a ball
disappear and then wang pops this out of
his mouth later in the scene jen hands
over a cease and desist which he makes
disappear and in the next shot we can
see this sticking out of the corner of
his shirt we then cut to finley's which
might be a reference to stan finley a
lawyer from the comics jen's on a date
but it doesn't go too well with her even
getting referred to as maybe a six yeah
she's like a six maybe i'd give you one
hey i'd give you one hey and after this
falls flat she ends up showing that
she's she-hulk now there's a really nice
little detail here and in the previous
scene she gets a matching a vacation
which donnie recognizes the sound of
oh shoo
someone's unmatcher ooh let's match you
this sound is also used again by her
date whilst she's on it showing he was
still trying to hook up with people
whilst he was with her i'm running a
superhuman law division
go to the trial and i am expecting to
see stuff like this every week this in
the last episode how i think the series
will go with it being a sort of
procedural weekly thing that involves
new cases each entry so if you hate this
congratulations it's probably not going
to be for you but if you like it
also congratulations you're gonna love
it now wang ends up calling in madison
and who has a rave in the middle of the
day mate i had one in ant-man as well
and like
who does this and how do i get invited
now she also brings up how she made a
deal with a demon called jake who we end
up seeing in the credits as a goat the
judge rules in favor of donny even after
a warning from wong and this ends up
leading to the ripple through dimensions
that pull forth several demons though
not exactly like the ones in the comics
they actually look somewhat similar the
ones that appeared in sensational
she-hulk 15. this had jen working with
howard the dark and several of the
creatures popped up like a swarm similar
to what happens in the episode now they
interrupt jen's day but before this we
see her going through profiles there's a
couple of big ones here including allen
who's listed as being a television host
this is actually alan tatcha a mexican
tv presenter finally made it to the mcu
and after the matches roll in we see her
on a date now this is with david otunga
who you'll likely recognize if you're a
wrestling fan david was a
lawyer-turned-wrestler which was all
part of his persona so it's a nice
little nod to have him popping up in the
show here he talks about how much he can
lift and he does look a bit like the guy
in the venice beach credits image so
maybe that was a deleted scene that was
meant to go on from this moment might
not be might be a reach but either way
all the men suck she seems to find a
nice guy after going through a film
director who made a movie about a lawyer
and also a very big fan he says he saw
the titania battle and gets giddy
thinking that she might be
indestructible weird little question
here though when he asks if his skin is
penetrable with vibranium impenetrable
skin yeah my skin is impenetrable at
least with
anything on earth even vibranium now
there was one of the wrecking crew last
week who wore a mask and he talked like
this
once you turned into she-hulk i couldn't
pierce that nasty green skin damn it i
was gonna be mad
to me they sound kind of similar and
this might actually be the same guy that
would be a neat little twist and tie in
with the questions that he's asking here
i think anyway now her final date seems
to listen and be interested in her and
across town we cut to donny who we learn
has been dropping women off around the
country the audience is now bored by his
tricks too and he ends up trying to pull
off the same thing that wong was about
to do in the office this unleashes a
dove that lays eggs with demons inside
and wong has to step away from his shows
and put an end to it now this room also
has several posters that reference other
magicians and showmen this includes
robert heller harry houdini and howard
thurston it's probably the biggest
action scene in the series so far with
us seeing a gateway to another dimension
this looks similar to the hellscape that
we saw during the multiverse of madness
and wong also opens the portal up to
some icy mountains it reminded me a lot
of when strange was sent to a mountain
during the first movie and these poor
little guys probably gonna freeze to
death so who's the real monster eh who's
the real monster now finally a cease and
desist is agreed to and jen heads home
for some hookups so slug i don't know
why i worded it like that but we'll
leave it in the video now every guy with
a big girl fetish they just cream their
pants over this moment but the next day
things don't go too well in another note
to titania we get a text from nikki
talking about her making the news and we
learn that she's being credible charges
to make matters worse it turns out that
she's suing jen for the name she hulk
and it's about to go down
anyway it's sue time three time big time
eater
how long can this become for my sitter
now as i mentioned last week i think
they are setting her up to be the big
bad of the show as she kind of went out
like a chump in the first episode
they've slowly laced her throughout
everything and the first she hulk run
all built up to the pair fighting one
another at the supreme court i'm sick of
mentioning that easter egg because i
bring it up every video but i think
we'll probably see another showdown
between the pair at some point the blood
plot could tie into it too with titania
trying to enhance herself through using
her dna in the comics mallory buck
actually worked with a company that
tried to tear down she-hulk and in her
place they wanted to make their own
version burke appeared in the episode
last week and she could be working
alongside titania to tear jen down i do
think that this series needs to have a
bit more stakes so introducing a plot
like this could really elevate it all
anyway that's enough too it was a bit
quick wasn't it anyway the credits of
madison signing a contract with jake and
she held cleans the demon blood off
herself we also see wong with donny
trapped in the mirror dimension before
we cut to the post-credits scene we see
madison and wong chilling together and
hopefully this is a netflix and chill
have blossoms into a beautiful romance
anyway as were my thoughts on the
episode again this was okay i don't feel
like it's a must-watch every week but i
am enjoying it a bit better than the
earlier episodes now i kind of know what
the stakes are and my expectations have
been lowered always good seeing wong
show up and this was a fun little
episode even if i probably won't
remember at the minute that i put the
video live now i do kind of want more
from this show and for them to really
get more of the stakes that the comics
had but i get that's not what they're
really aiming for and that it's just
meant to be exactly like this i think
that the episodes are too short to
really develop anything and most of the
events are so forgettable that you feel
like you're just watching a series on
autopilot to me anyway i'm glad people
are enjoying it but i'm finding very
little substance to it i'm also not
saying that you're an idiot because you
like it yeah i just for me personally
it's not really doing that much i think
a big issue with marvel shows in general
is that they tend to focus too firmly on
one character to the point that all of
the side characters just feel like set
dressing for example you watch a show
like house of dragons you have viserys
getting his own arc and going off on his
own tangent ronira has large parts of
the episode dedicated to her damon has
his own storyline and most tv shows in
general tend to have a cast of
characters that prop everything up look
at the boys for example you have
homelander a train the deep billy
butcher huey annie and so many different
characters that will take the focus from
time to time i think one division
succeeded because it shifted back and
forth between wonder and sword but most
of the other disney shows tend to just
keep the focus on one person because of
this to me it feels kind of
underdeveloped when we talk about the
overall cast and rather than getting
numerous characters that we're invested
in you just tend to follow the one so
whether you like them or not is very
make a break now this is definitely just
a comedy so it will very much live and
die on whether the jokes work for you or
not again i think they're okay but with
us still having five weeks left i'm
hoping that they do a bit more the
performances are all great and tatiana
once more is really carrying the entire
thing but in terms of all the other tv
shows that are out at the moment
yeah
it's just not at the level that they are
i don't feel personally now it is nice
to see an actress just really making the
role here oh no and it's difficult to
imagine anyone else doing this i just
wish the material was a bit more higher
caliber again i'm not saying it's
terrible but it's okay it could be
better now this is actually the end of
my i know you hate me already you're
gonna tell me in the comments how much
of a idiot i am but you know i'm all
about free speech and if you want to do
that knock yourself out mate and go
knock yourself out literally now this is
actually the end of my early access and
i am away next week so the video might
be up a bit later due to me just having
to coordinate stuff with my editors
it'll probably still be out on thursday
but yeah that's just a heads up so you
aren't sitting up all night waiting
anyway thank you for clicking this video
and obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the show below we are in a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of top gun maverick on the
15th of september and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe the
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then guess what we've got a
great tv show on screen right now house
of the bloody dragon the breakdown is
over there i'll see you there soon you
take hey sub mate and i hope to see on
the next one if you're not do not
realize i'm gonna hate this show forever
and it's never gonna be worth watching
one of my breakdowns but i appreciate
you sticking through this one you take
care yourself peace